today is a big day for people who have  been left behind today is a big day for  workers in Appalachia today is a big day  for children that have been breathing  dirty air in the South Bronx today is a  really good day for families who have  been enduring the in Justices of  drinking dirty water or who have seen  their living rooms being flooded in with  the waves of flooded in with with the  waves of rising sea sea levels and today  I think is a really big day for our  economy the labor movement the social  justice movement indigenous peoples and  people all over the United States of  America today is the day that we truly  embark on a comprehensive agenda of  economic social and racial justice in  the United States of America